enough of the victimhood guys I saw this
video this is uh my buddy Michael
Knowles from the daily wire doing a
college event and they were not happy
with him they were screaming they were
shouting they were trying to silence a
speaker on college campuses which we all
know all too well uh and Knowles uh
mocked the victims of the faux
oppression quite well
I know you're so oppressed my dears I
know
you have to live in the richest most
Equitable most just country in the
history of the world you have to get a
college education you have to
voluntarily go to lectures it's so awful
I can't imagine that you know the people
people who are in war-torn Nations they
must truly they must truly video goodbye
goodbye then
what the hell is even that
look
these kids you can't blame the kids
right you can't at some point like we
can make fun of these kids and okay it
is what it is but like you can't blame
the kids the education system has failed
them their parents have failed them the
institutions have failed them the school
there has failed them by not teaching
them the right things everything has
failed them and next thing you know
they're morbidly obese their penis is a
vagina and they're a little pissed you
men you wonder why
[Music]
foreign